it is one of the most special times of
the year for las vegas when the shriners
children's open at tpc takes place
events like this are so important to
families because it gives them hope and
here to tell us more is tammy robbins
the regional marketing director for
shriners children's and the national
patient ambassador sydney welcome you
guys thank you sydney first of all
congratulations on being an ambassador
tell me a little bit about your journey
and how shriners for children helped you
yeah so i was diagnosed with scoliosis
at the age of 10 and so i wore a back
brace for two years and did some
scoliosis treatment and did yoga and
tried everything to prevent surgery but
my curve was actually getting worse and
i had a 32 degree curve and so we were
looking at other options and a local
oklahoman told us about shriners and
about vbt the surgery that i had and so
literally like six months later we went
and we flew to philadelphia and had my
surgery and it was an amazing experience
now i don't know if a lot of people
understand how this works but you need
it it's i'm guessing a very expensive
surgery yes and what did you have to pay
for this nothing zero dollars zero
dollars that's why this is so important
tammy tell me a little bit about this
and how shriners is able to help so many
families well we're able to help so many
families because of generous donors and
a great endowment that we have built up
for a number of years you know over
almost 100 years and that helps us be
able to provide care to families like
sydney
regardless of their ability to pay so
it's a really important thing for us to
have events like this to not only raise
awareness about shriners hospital but
really bring people into the fold and
help them understand what a special
place shriners children's is to our
families and for everybody out there who
could use our care and and be a part of
our shriners it is such an amazing week
of events it's so touching to me people
like you sydney who have been touched
firsthand i mean what
what was it like what was the experience
like the doctors just everything that
you went through oh gosh i can't even
explain how amazing it was i remember
not wanting to leave the hospital i was
like can i just stay in the hospital
i was just so happy there my nurses were
amazing they just
really treat you personally it's not
just you're not just another patient to
them they really really care about you
and they look at you as an individual
and it's just unlike any other hospital
that i've ever been to and so it's
incredible and look at you representing
now and doing a great job at it tammy
how do people how do they help how do
they become a part of this great event
that's happening so you know we we
provide the most amazing care anywhere
we're leaders in pediatric orthopedics
burns cleft lip and palate so you can
just go to
shrinerschildrens.org or you can go to
shrinerschildrensopen.com
and buy tickets to
the tournament this weekend and come out
and sydney will be out there along with
her three fellow patient ambassadors and
lots of kids lots of shriners out there
in their fezes to come out and say thank
you to the las vegas community for
supporting this tournament and
supporting shriner's children it is such
a fun event i love going out there you
just walk around you can watch the pros
you can watch just people having fun
tell us a little bit about the actual
golf that's going on so we're very
excited about the field that we have for
for the golf this year some really great
big name players are coming out and we
couldn't be more excited for as a matter
of fact
zach johnson was out there today on the
driving range and surprised two of our
national ambassadors with
a surprise
lesson out on the driving range and
those guys have been so great to to our
patients so i think it's a really great
opportunity to come out and see some
outstanding golf get close up to the
players and i mean even with social
distancing in the way that we are living
these days you still can really see um
some fantastic golf i've been coming out
here for so many years and it's really
my favorite favorite time to see golf
it's such a fun time and yes you got to
check it out sydney congratulations
you're an amazing ambassador thank you
tammy so much we appreciate it shriner's
children's open october 7th through the
10th tpc summerland check it out you
don't want to miss it tickets are
available at
shrinerschildrensopen.com we'll be right
back
[Music]